[Music]
concerned um it seems inevitable it
feels like it was broadcast in the draft
decision that we saw this week
absolutely i think now
it feels like the gloves are off and
that every i mean when you begin to
question
um equal protection clause and before
the 14th amendment that extends the
marriage equality that's the reason we
have mayor dupoli that's the reason we
have loving versus virginia that's
reason we have um um what is it um
griswold versus connecticut so there's
so many decisions that are um dependent
on the equal protection clause so yeah
i'm absolutely concerned as far as next
steps go we have to vote
and we have to pay attention and if you
aren't using your voice now's the time
take to the streets do whatever you can
do
support organizations like glad like as4
like planned parenthood i think that uh
we have to pay very close attention to
what's happening currently in the
political climate right and that is uh
and that is a real thing
that all of us need to focus on and
continue to fight look we've been
fighting in our in the lgbtqi plus
community for decades it had in the
fight while we've seen successes the
fight has not ended and yes what we saw
last week with the draft uh with the
draft document is is is scary uh it is
radical
it is atrocious and so it is important
for us to continue to lift our voices up
and to speak out against it lgbtq rights
are human rights women's rights are
human rights we are not free unless all
of us is free so they're uh we have to
stand up and fight for every single
human
every single citizen of the united
states no matter what you look like or
how you identify or what sexuality you
may maintain you have every right to be
in this country and to live a free and
equal life as the person standing next
to you
you